i never even bought dope
there was so much floating around
they were all selling dope i didn't get
in that game but i certainly took it
when they handed it to me um
so a lot of stuff was free a lot of
stuff was cheap uh the great thing about
the hippies is
um
even the ones who didn't have to
pretended to be poor i was sort of one
of those i lived in a 20 a month
apartment in north beach if you can
imagine that
these days
um
and
you point out a wonderful thing in the
book which i can recommend
um
from time to time i would write my
mother and
he's read all these letters
that i wrote my mother from camp on
and my god what's in there
but part of why i was doing it was
at the end of these very informative
family letters i would say oh by the way
do you think you could maybe send
a hundred dollars
whenever it's convenient
and she would do that
and so i was
just
sort of in a trickling way
subsidized
and and i'll rap on this
so it meant that i didn't have to get a
job
and the thing that brian you know says
to art students now routinely is
um you're going to go out of here and
and you can't make money yet probably at
what you really want to do and you're
going to be tempted to get a job please
don't do
because if you do that and then you see
something or somebody or you have an
idea there's an opportunity to go
somewhere you won't be able to act on it
and you need to be able to act on things
right away
and so don't have a job
and thanks to my mother and that little
subsidy that came along from time to
time by request
i was able to not have a job
and
not have a career